The last personality disorder that we're going to discuss, some of you may of
heard of. It's called, antisocial personality disorder, or ASPD. Now this is
formally know as psychopathic or sociopathic behavior. Now antisocial
personality disorder, is a serious and potentially dangerous disorder. It is
marked by extremely impulsive deceptive, violent, ruthless and callous
behavior. The key here is antisocial personality disorder focuses on outward
behaviors. Where as the term, psychopath typically focuses on inward
characteristics. People with antisocial personality disorder are more likely to
engage in criminal, deceptive and violent behaviors. For example, an individual
with this disorder may break the law repeatedly. Be able to act charming and
witty, steal and fight often. They won't show guilt or remorse, and they can
become very angry and arrogant. Now, they're really good at manipulating other
people, and have a complete disregard for the safety of others. Many more men
than women have this disorder. And it's common among people in prison. As with
other disorders, genetic and environmental factors are known to contribute. For
example, children who suffered from child abuse people with an antisocial
parent, or people with alcoholic parents, are at an increased risk for
developing this disorder. In addition a lot of research has revealed, that
those are the antisocial personality disorder, especially the violent
criminals, have amygdala that are unusually distorted in size, activity, and
function.